since you mentioned uh uaps uh we talked
about intelligence and I forgot to ask
what what's your view on the other
possible intelligences that are out
there at the uh the meso scale do you
think there's other intelligent alien
civilizations is that useful to think
about how often do you think about it I
think it's I think it's useful to think
about it's useful to think about because
we got to ensure we're anti- fragile
and we're you know trying to increase
our capabilities as fast as possible
because we could get disrupted like
there's no laws of physics against
their uh being life elsewhere that could
evolve and become an advanced
civilization and and eventually come to
us uh do I think they're here now I'm
not sure uh I mean I've I've I've read
what most people have read on the the
topic um I think it's interesting to
consider and to me it's a useful thought
experiment to instill a sense of urgency
in developing Technologies and
increasing our capabilities to make sure
we don't get disrupted right whether
it's a form of of AI that disrupts us or
a foreign intelligence from a different
planet like either way like increasing
our capabilities and becoming formid
formidable as humans um I think that's
that's really important so that we're
robust against whatever the universe
throws at us but to me it's also
interest an interesting
Challenge and thought experiment on how
to perceive intelligence this has to do
with quantum mechanical systems it has
to do with with any kind of system
that's not like
humans so to me the thought experiment
is say the aliens are here or they are
directly observable we're just too blind
too
self-centered um don't have the right
sensors or don't have the right
processing of the sensor data to see the
obvious intelligence that's all around
us well that's why we work on Quantum
sensors right they can sense gravity
yeah gra but there could be so that's a
good one but there could be other stuff
that's not even the in the uh currently
known forces of physics right there
could be some other
stuff and the most entertaining thought
experiment to me is that it's other
stuff that's obvious it's not like we
don't we lack the sensors it's all
around us you know you know the the
Consciousness being one possible one but
there could be stuff that's just like
obviously there that once you know it
it's like oh right right that's that's
that the thing we thought is somehow
emergent from the laws of physics we
understand them is actually a
fundamental part
of the universe and can be incorporated
in physics what
understood statistically speaking right
if we observe some sort of alien life it
would most likely be some sort of
virally
self-replicating Von noyman like probe
system right and and it's
possible that there you know there are
such systems that I don't know what
they're doing at the bottom of the ocean
allegedly but maybe they're you know
collecting minerals from the bottom of
the ocean yeah um but that wouldn't VI
violate any of my prior but am I certain
that these systems are here and it it'd
be difficult for me to say so right I
only have secondhand information about
there being data about the bottom of the
ocean yeah but you know could it be
things like memes could it be thoughts
and
ideas could they be operating in that
Medium could aliens be the very thoughts
that come into my
head like what do you have you H how do
you know that how do you know that the
what's the origin of ideas in your mind
what an idea comes to your head show me
where it originates I mean
frankly uh when I had the idea for the
type of computer I'm building now I
think it was eight years ago now it
really felt like it was being beamed
from
space just I was in bed just shaking
just thinking it through and I don't
know um but do I believe that
legitimately I don't think so I but you
know I I think that um alien life could
take many forms and I think the notion
of intelligence and the notion of Life
needs to be expanded uh much more
broadly uh to be less
anthropocentric or
biocentric